deuxième pièce du dossier maintenant
l'avenir nous dit-on encore récemment
c'est la banque en ligne celle que l'on
joint par téléphone ou par internet fini
le guichet classique et bien les choses
ne vont pas aussi vite loin de là
aujourd'hui trois millions et demi de
français consultent certes régulièrement
leur compte sur internet mais l' agence
classique a encore de belles années de
vie devant elle qui sont ces adeptes de
la banque en ligne ouverte jour et nuit
reportage françois beaudonnet valérie
criton
23h30 un restaurant branché de l'ouest
parisien pascal est cadre supérieur dans
un grand groupe français la soirée est
amicale mais la note un peu salée à
minuit son compte courant risque de
passer dans le rouge elle décide
d'intervenir
à l'autre bout du fil changement
d'ambiance malgré l'heure ils sont une
dizaine au travail ce soir cet homme
sera son banquier où il pense pas
courant s'il vous plaît comme en
français durée de la communication 2
minutes 30 je vous en prie madame à
connecter dans ce format
oui merci bonsoir l avantage c'est que
vous voyez il est
tahar est en fête
on peut effectivement faire retrouver à
n'importe quelle heure du jour de la
nuit sont toujours là à nous répondre un
système surtout pratique pour les
opérations simples car pour le reste le
problème est que le client ne parle
jamais aux mêmes conseillers ici c'est
avant tout la rapidité qui compte on
travaille en temps réel ce que les
grosses banques ne peuvent pas se
permettre de faire aujourd'hui nos
clients quand ils font une opération sur
internet il appelle deux minutes après
un conseiller au téléphone notre client
et notre conseiller ont le même niveau
d'information ce qui fait que le conseil
est pertinent et qualité la qualité et
les prix de la banque à distance c'est
justement ce que tu est deux fois par an
ce site internet cette année surprise
les banques en ligne ne sont plus
forcément moins cher que les banques
traditionnelles il est très étonnant de
constater que les banques ce qu'on
appelle les banques en dur
développe davantage aujourd'hui les
services en ligne que ne le font les
banques en lignes pures et puis là le
deuxième enseignement qui est aussi une
bonne surprise pour les clients c'est
que on a une nette amélioration des prix
une baisse sensible des prix
mais même avec des tarifs en baisse les
banque à distance ne séduisent une
clientèle très particulière des cadres
ou des professions libérales adepte du
net alors qu'on annonce et leur mort il
ya cinq ans les banques traditionnelles
ont donc encore de beaux jours devant
elle